can i be a colonist to capitalist just
for a brief second ready
five thousand barrels that's nothing you
could see some of the other oils
that's a that's a light oil spill
[Music]
this is star talk
i'm your host neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist
and today we're going to talk about
environmental science
and
what it means to even be engaged in that
if you're in the west or somewhere else
well
let's find out what that means in a
minute i've got with me my co-host
marcia belski marcia welcome back to
star trek yay thank you so much for
having me i'm so excited to be here i'm
excited for this topic too i'm really
really excited to hear about this
really it's a really it's a topic that
everyone ought to know about and most
people don't even know exactly exactly
so that's that's where i see this and so
what we have here is a world expert on
indigenous
environmental studies who even knew that
that was a thing i've got jessica
hernandez jessica welcome to star talk
thank you for having me here today
excellent excellent and
get your academic pedigree on the table
here you have a phd from uw did i say
that right
yes
university of washington in seattle and
that phd was environmental and forest
sciences okay another under appreciated
feature of the world are our forests
they also have a masters of marine
affairs which sounds like some secret
office of the pentagon or something you
know the few the proud the marines so
does marine have a very specific
definition other than
uh
when i think of marines i think marinas
with boats but surely there's a
scientific
meaning for that word yeah so marina
first is like very an interdisciplinary
program so it focuses on like ocean
science and also fresh water sciences
but it also integrates the policy so one
of the classes that we had to take was
international ocean law which is like a
different field from you know what we
are used to as scientists
wow you know an equivalent thing to that
is space law right it's another place
where there isn't a country but we still
have to cooperate as humans so we might
have a lot to learn in space law by
whatever you guys have uh arrived this
is the international law
like what they call like boat law it's
always a movie plot device so they're
like
international waters where you can like
they just cross the border there the
boundary they're now in international
waters so we can bomb them out yeah or
do marine research so
so yeah and jessica more importantly or
i'm not going to value judge one thing
you do or another but for the world more
importantly you're an environmental
advocate and that's so important but you
have a totally
different outlook on this and i'm
delighted to learn that you wrote a book
that highlights so much of this work and
a great i love the title fresh banana
leaves
what the hell is that about and then we
go to the subtitle um healing indigenous
landscapes through indigenous science
so let's just start right out what is it
we can learn from indigenous science
that
quote traditional science
either doesn't know or can't learn or
we're ignorant to or in denial of so
what are you bringing to the table
coming from that place yeah thank you
for your question and i think one of the
ways that i look at indigenous science
is that you know a metaphor that i like
to give the audience is like indigenous
science kind of looks like the completed
puzzle versus western sciences we focus
on the puzzle pieces right so we focus
typically on two or three so we're
missing to look at the holistic or the
entire picture in this sense and
indigenous science the way that is um
you know created as a framework we put
our spirituality and our identities at
the front and center of it versus in
western science as you both know right
it follows the scientific method where
we are told to remove ourselves our
spirituality from the western science in
the name of objectivity so indigenous
science in a way connects our
relationships that as humans we have
with nature and how we are a part of
nature nature is a part of us so that's
the differences that i usually tell the
audience especially when comparing and
contrasting western science and
indigenous science so i think a
philosopher would say that science
modern science as we now think of it in
the schools is reductionist and whereas
what you're describing is more holistic
right because if you're reductionist i'm
not looking at the whole puzzle i it's
this corner of the puzzle and i and i
know exactly how this piece fits that
piece and i'm so close to those two
pieces i have no idea what the whole
puzzle looks like
uh because i've focused and whereas if
you are holistic
your you're factoring in everything but
is that always a better thing to do
i think um it has ups and downs right
because i sometimes you know you can
kind of
invest a lot of time trying to you know
look at the entire puzzle piece but one
of the things that i often see in the
western sciences is by us focusing on
two or three puzzle pieces or like you
mentioned the corner of the puzzle we
end up creating more harm especially as
it pertains to our environments
especially as it pertains to people and
given that you know we have racial
injustices that are interconnected to
environmental injustices to climate
injustices oftentimes as scientists we
end up creating more harm than good so i
think that you know that's the the um
pros of you know looking at the entire
puzzle piece so that we can reduce the
harm that we generate as a scientist
i feel like admitting the human aspect
to kind of makes the whole thing more
honest because it's like with what like
with western science or whatever you
call it like modern science there is
always humanness and human opinions and
human decisions in it because i remember
reading about how when they decided how
to model dna it like came down to these
two software modeling companies and one
had way more money and so that's like
kind of where they went but like western
science is kind of in denial of all the
sociology involved in
that so it's like so i think at its best
that sociology will
determine what gets researched yeah but
at the end what deter what is determined
to be true uh i think they try to make
it objective yeah yeah yeah at that
point but you're right it totally
affects the funding and what people
study or more importantly to just to
jessica's point what people even care
about yeah right right at
the end but okay so so jessica there's a
there's an extract from some indigenous
tree and i don't remember which you
surely know the tree from which we
derived the active ingredient in aspirin
and so that's been extracted again it's
reductionist no don't chew on the bark
because who knows what else is in the
bark plus that might not be fun here it
is in a pill
so
what happened there is some indigenous
medicine became
uh scientifically uh verified
and so now that's just science right so
so why should indigenous science be
something different from
modern science why isn't it just you
found something that's true we check it
in the lab yep it's true now it's
science why can't we think of it that
way
i think one of the the things that i can
think of is like how western science is
kind of founded on colonialism right
when we look at who is considered the
founders or the pioneers of many
scientific disciplines they're white
european men who came to the americas
and kind of you know formulated their
own philosophies based on you know
western religion that they introduce
into the americas and i think that with
indigenous science it kind of addresses
that colonialism right because when we
look at our landscapes when we look at
the ancestral knowledge that have been
that has been passed down to us
especially you know from my grandparents
from my parents to myself
you know part of our history has been
fractured because of colonialism but yet
we're still trying to fight those
nuances that western or modern science
kind of dismisses especially as it
pertains to indigenous peoples one being
like you mentioned examples of our
traditional medicinal plants or the
medicine that we practice and how we can
compare that to how western medicine is
practiced today right where they're also
looking at one puzzle piece and they're
giving you you know medicine for
whatever you're going into the doctor
for but in reality the long-term effects
you know it has other impacts in your
overall health so i think that you know
that's an example that you know the
foundation of colonialism and how that's
embedded in the modern or western
science fiction
i like that that the medicine they
prescribe for that one ailment is a
puzzle piece because they're not looking
at the whole thing they just got this
one ailment we give you this one pill
and then come back you know later for
another pill maybe uh so so you speak
you're speaking in first person are you
a descendant of uh indigenous peoples
yeah so i'm maya chorti so my myer
church community comes from central
america so we are at the border of el
salvador guatemala honduras and my par
my father was actually displaced during
the central american civil war where he
was actually 11 years old when he was
forced to be a child soldier in that war
and then i also come from the south
patek communities which is are located
in oaxaca and that's where my father
eventually received refuge
as he was making his journey up to the
united states to receive asylum and
that's where he met my mom so i come
from both communities in that sense
okay so you not only got the you got it
in your in your family but now you have
the academic side of it to go with it so
that that ought to make you pretty
potent in these conversations when you
have to convince people's people of what
they need to do
so so tell me about climate change and
indigenous
and go
tell us about climate
two minutes give change your best two
minute answer
i guess to give yeah to give my
two-minute solution
um when we look at indigenous
communities especially our relatives our
communities who are living in our
ancestral lands one of the things that i
can notice is that we are already facing
the climate change impacts right when we
look at latin america latin america
is the house for 50 of the world's
biodiversity so we're seeing how even
despite colonialism capitalism all these
western ideologies being introduced into
our lands we're still storing and
caretaking for 50 of the world's
biodiversity but just to be clear the
amazon basin is most of that isn't that
right yes and yes
and we see how even like you know the
indigenous communities in the amazon are
facing extreme violence because you know
they're going against these
international agricultural corporations
multi-billion dollar corporations are
trying to deforest the amazon rainforest
and i think that through that many
indigenous communities are trying to
mitigate climate change but oftentimes
when we talk about in the western
science or in the international scope
where we're kind of focusing more on the
adaptation strategies but you know in
indigenous communities we're mitigating
those impacts by going against
extractive energy resources by going
against you know agricultural
corporations that are kind of
introducing monoculture that are you
know it's kind of in at the end of the
day destroying the biodiversity but yet
you know when it comes to the climate
change discourse and going to these
international forums indigenous voices
are nowhere to be found right they often
talk about us but they don't include us
at the table or allow us to lead those
tables or conversations
this is a big issue i mean i mean so so
this goes beyond
science this is policy and and when you
mention sort of the the colonistic
cultures
descending on
the native cultures
yeah i i don't have a problem when you
say they brought their science with them
but the real oppressive parts of it is
not so much i would think it's not so
much the science but their way of
way of living and their way of
conducting business and their way
of how they think of themselves relative
to other people you know because every
colonist is like i'm great and you're
not and i deserve this and you don't and
my god says it's better than your god
and that's a whole i i don't want to
call that science because it's not yeah
because it's like science should just be
indigenous science until
religion and colonialism and capitalism
all these things come into play that
change it into this destructive
yeah this whole this whole soup of yeah
of of of forces
that probably don't have one
force that
that probably don't have only one
solution it's going to be a
multi-pronged solution because it's kind
of like you like you said marsha it's
coming from economics and culture and
religion and all of these bits and
pieces that we call civilization
yeah and you're fighting it's
interesting because it's like i feel
like it's kind of what's happening in
every area where it's understanding
these great forces like
and you're fighting against it locally
you know and it's like well we can
protect like what we still have but then
you're still fighting against people
trying to take that and encroach on you
know the land that is protected right we
got to take a quick break but when we
come back i want to take a deep dive
into that biodiversity question i i i
didn't know that like it was 50 percent
of the roles of biodiversity is in latin
america that's an amazing me neither
yeah i knew the amazon basement would
have a lot of whatever it had but for it
to be that much even of the whole world
um and and just to watch
the the contest the conflict between
indigenous peoples and the west that
basically
the west what europe basically that
wanted to conquer the world so when we
come back more of indigenous peoples and
their role in
saving the planet on star talk
we're back star talk
this is on indigenous environment saving
the planet
the conflict between western science and
what indigenous peoples know
about the land that they're on and the
holistic
caring of the earth it's all here
it's we've got it all it's all wrapped
up in the expertise of one human being
uh jessica hernandez uh and
jessica do you do are you
a full-time environmental activist now
what is your affiliations
right now i'm doing research so i'm
stationed at the university of
washington bottle and i'm doing actually
research on environmental physics so
kind of looking at climate science from
the energy perspective especially given
that energy is a core concept that's
taught in physics so it's kind of
interesting
yeah it definitely is yeah there's this
it's like half of physics is what what
is the energy doing now and what shape
is it taking so the more you can get in
there the better so so we left off we
were talking about the biodiversity of
the world and so much of it being in
latin america
um but tell me
how what area how much of earth's
surface is
is indigenous i know australia there's a
lot of sort of aboriginal lands and
australia is a large con still
indigenous
last i checked there was you know the
land given unto
the aboriginal uh people so i'm just
wondering jessica what's the latest on
that on this relationship between
the original peoples and everybody who
came later
one of the things that i see especially
in the global conflicts is that
indigenous communities are still
fighting for those land rights as we all
know right nobody wants to give up their
land especially land that has been
stolen from people um especially
indigenous peoples we have a unique
history right when we talk about like
for instance the continents of australia
the continents of africa the continents
of south america and also north america
and i think that is very different in
each community especially in each
continent but for instance in the
americas
we are seeing some indigenous movements
that are reclaiming land rights
especially the land and one of the
movements that i talk about in my book
fresh banana leaves is the sapatistas
movement so the zapatista movement was
actually led by indigenous women even
though when you look at the zapatista
movement if you were to google the men
are actually the ones that are amplified
even though it's an indigenous woman-led
movement because you know we know that
patriarchy is still embedded in
environmentalism and that movement
basically the indigenous communities of
south mexico in the in the state of
chiapas decided that they were going to
overtake the
capital of their state and actually burn
land deeds in the municipal towns so by
burning land deeds right nobody had
ownership of their lands anymore so they
reclaimed their lands through that way
it was a peaceful resistance movement
ironically the mexican government didn't
enact any violence against them to stop
them so they were successful in that
sense so that's a you know an example of
how i can think of indigenous peoples
having to reclaim their land rights but
obviously it's not something that's
automatically given to them but we're
seeing that as um as we speak today even
in the global context
well so my only american counterpart to
that was in the 1960s when uh people
resisting the vietnam war would burn
their draft cards right so they're
burning the paper
claim on their life
all right and so if you burn the land
deed that's brilliant if you bernal
andy's there are no land there's still
there's a lot of like even in america
like united states of america there's
all this like pipeline
protests like because
you know they're taking land that was
promised over treaty and being like
never mind and kind of everybody's
looking the other way
you can do if no one's looking right do
you need advocacy yeah precisely
otherwise you you know you get
steamrolled well yeah so
so tell me how much of the world is
overseen by indigenous people of the
world's land yeah so the stat says that
even though we make you know indigenous
peoples make less than five percent of
the world's population we're storing
eighty percent of the world's
biodiversity so that 80 percent you know
it's it's a drastic percentage
especially when we talk about
biodiversity and you know the entire
world in that context
wow okay so then
okay so then it's up up to you to
protect it
i mean
how do you how does someone reply to
that if you got 80 of it fix it you know
or do do something
so i think that oftentimes you know we
are still like even like marcia was
mentioning like the pipelines right we
still see how when we're trying to
protect our landscapes or our lands we
are faced with extreme violence i think
with you know the prime example that we
all witnessed was what was happening at
standing rock right where the police
were actually using tear gas or military
equipment to stop those protests because
you know they didn't want to listen to
indigenous peoples tell me about the
give me some specific examples of
what
what indigenous peoples are doing with
regard to forests and the oceans that
others could be doing that could help
things
all right so one of the things that i
can think of is in my zapotec community
in nation we are made up of different
pueblos or different tribes we are
actually stewarding a forest right so
we're actually um leading
timber um companies or timber
quarters of businesses where we actually
are not necessarily deforesting the
entire forest but we're you know taking
timber in a way that allows us to take
the timber from older um trees when
they're mature but it still allows the
trees to grow again right so it's not
necessarily getting rid of the entire
tree it's kind of cutting it in a way
where we're using our traditional
knowledge to cut what we need especially
to sell timber in that sense and i think
you know when we look at the timber
industry especially when we are looking
at even mentioning books right there is
a paper shortage because of the pandemic
and also because we have cut down so
many trees so in that regards um that's
an example of how we can actually still
use those natural resources that are you
know that our society depends on without
destroying the entire resource itself
right so in this case the tree another
example that i can think of is also how
we view agriculture right so in my
communities we have these systems known
as milpas and these milpas are holistic
agricultural systems where they don't
necessarily need much men labor like
western agriculture where these meal
pass kind of generate themselves you
know obviously we pray to them we do
ceremonies especially before we harvest
and we also have animals that live there
that also nourish us right in oaxaca we
consume a lot of grasshoppers and
insects because they're rich
you know we make our grasshoppers which
you know in in western um diets you know
it's like um what is it it's rare right
to eat grasshoppers but in that sense
you know rare doesn't really capture the
fact whatever they're eating frogs in
louisiana and stuff it's like people are
eating whatever
no no frog legs are okay grasshoppers
but i gotta draw the line somewhere
so you're like
i've had i've had
pan-fried grasshoppers before they're
crunchy and
um i don't know if you know a little
salt and pepper they were fine i
definitely think the way i'm socialized
i always scares me because it's always
like when the apocalypse comes are you
gonna be able to like eat bugs or eat
everything and people who can live off
the land obviously have such an
advantage and i'm like
i don't know i eat like mac and cheese
out of the box
you're the first to go
you're the first wave of death
i like to think i could eat a
grasshopper but we'll see we'll see
so i heard you mentioned trees just to
be clear you are harvesting parts like
limbs of the tree for your needs and
then the tree just continues to grow so
you at no point do you kill the tree for
those needs is that good did i
understand you correctly that's correct
and i think that you know western
science still needs to in a way um catch
up to the indigenous knowledge that we
have yeah we're not even thinking that
way yeah
i feel like they could think that way
but a company would look at that and say
why would we take a slower and less
amount of product if we can like
just take it all it's like you said
they're not thinking about the whole
thing they're just thinking about the
pieces and their piece is their specific
company and if everybody's doing that
but if everybody actually adopted
sustainable practices and not just like
going green for a commercial you know
what i mean so that they can advertise
like our offices have cut down energy by
five percent you know
well wait wait so so
isn't it still sustainable to cut down a
tree but then plant another tree isn't
that still creating some kind of
equilibrium it's a more violent
equilibrium of course but isn't that
still what
i mean i was amazed growing up how is it
that every year
there are christmas trees available
right so there's got to be some
somewhere
because because you you're buying a tree
that's older than a year
right
so
somewhere the growing trees
at a faster rate than we're using them
otherwise we would have run out of trees
right so
so
isn't there isn't it possible to have an
equilibrium of new trees versus trees
you cut down
i think one of the the
important things to mention is that you
know when we're trying to talk about
mitigating climate change right like
we're trying to reduce the amount of
greenhouse gases and we know that trees
um kind of you know help us mitigate
those impacts you know a tree takes
years or generations to actually mature
into a bigger tree i know that for
christmas trees there are you know kind
of like um farms to just you know grow
those trees so
i had to conclude because i did the math
and it wasn't working over honestly
creepy if you've ever driven by a
christmas tree farm it's really creepy
because it's like a suburb where all the
houses look the same like they're
awesome
all the trees are the same heights it's
really weird
in a line yeah and everything it's
really weird
um
i have a possibly sensitive question i'm
not sure
so
uh not to generalize all indigenous
peoples of the world but there does
appear to be a common theme
where
ancestral knowledge is cherished
and it gets handed down from generation
to generation and no one wants that to
be lost
lest you break off an entire branch of
wisdom that had been there ever since
the the dawn of things
um is is that a fair generalization of
course there are detailed differences i
would expect
but um because i want to make a
different point related to it but is it
am i is it fair to make that
generalization
yeah and i i think that you know one of
the examples that we can look at is
slavery right because the slavery was
stealing indigenous peoples from the
continent of africa and kind of ripping
them apart from their roots and bringing
them into the americas to caretake and
steward the lands right nobody taught
them how to do that and i think that
through that right um i know that you
know not every indigenous person agrees
with me but i always include um our
black relatives into in the indigene
discourses because you know they have
indigenous roots that were stolen from
them and one of the ways that they were
able to kind of fracture that
indigeneity was through you know
separating families and we saw those
tactics even used in boarding schools
right where indigenous children were
ripped from their families
so that they can be assimilated and we
and we it's very parallel to what
happened in slavery and i think that
oftentimes you know that's a that's a
great statement to make because we saw
those things happen in the past
especially as it pertains to black and
indigenous peoples in the continent of
the americas did you actually use the
word indigeneity
yes oh very cool word oh my god okay so
here's my here is my question to you
then isn't an aspect of that problem
that many of the indigenous peoples did
not have writing as a tradition
because when you have writing as a
tradition nothing gets forgotten
it just gets put in a book and now our
next generation can read the book and
compare it to other new discoveries and
then it it becomes part of the culture
with no risk lest there be a library
fire with no risk of it getting
permanently lost
so why doesn't somebody just write down
all of these traditions and then we have
this canon of indigenous
um uh uh holistic ways and then we can
go page by page and say you know we
tested that in the laboratory we have a
better way for that hey we never knew
about that
let's try that out how come that's not
happening we all see how yoga went so
i'm sure that would go well if we put it
all into a book and then
westerners could just charge people to
read it yeah
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off
i think that it's important to mention
that some of our ancestors actually had
a writing systems right when we look at
the mayan civilization and when we look
at even the oaxaca indigenous
communities we had kodi says which were
ridden um ancient you know kind of like
our writing style but they were burned
during colonization a lot of our regalia
our traditional clothing actually coming
from a family that embroiders and does
regalia for our communities we write our
own stories through the art through the
embroidering of the flowers but yet when
we look at how colonization
addressed that they burned those items
because they were you know because of
western christianity they were kind of
relating that to you know worshiping the
devil worshiping evil spirits so they
burn a lot of that we have some cordises
you know our written
writing styles and stones
kept behind museum glass doors right to
the ones that were actually not burned
and they're in europe so how do we have
access to those things that these
multi-billion dollar museums are
actually you know keeping behind museum
glass doors when in reality you know
that can be used for us to also pass
down the knowledge and reclaim some of
the knowledge that was you know stolen
and lost because of colonization and all
the um well of course there's been an
ongoing movement to decolonize uh
museums and other institutions
that exist
all the fruits of indigenous peoples in
through the lenses of western folk
so we're going to take a quick break uh
but i want to remind people that you
have a new book and the first two words
are banana leaves and you have to just
before we go to break just explain the
banana leaves because i it caught it did
catch my attention mind you but i now
i'm forcing you to tell me a little more
about those two words
so banana trees are actually non-native
plants to central america and i think
that one of the reasons why entitled
fresh banana leaves is because banana
trees while they were introduced into
central america they have become our
relatives right when we look at central
america cuisine and in our food and a
traditional foods like our tamales and
everything else that we make we
incorporate those banana leaves and i
think that that's a history that many
indigenous communities in the americas
that have banana leaves into their diets
kind of have that relationship with
banana trees as it relates to them
becoming a relative and also a displaced
relative and we can talk more about that
in the morning wow okay so it's not only
a literal but metaphorical reference to
an entire
way of living
and it also kind of ties to my father's
story especially his story when he was a
child soldier
at the age of 11 he was forcefully
um made to join either the guerrilla or
the military the government military so
he joined the guerrilla and one of his
stories that he tells me is that banana
trees even though they were introduced
into central america they became their
only food source right when we look at
the guerrilla and guerrillas in central
america they were made up of indigenous
children fighting against the oppressive
government structures especially the
government structures that introduced
these plantations that were forcing
indigenous children to work for you know
pennies often times for just a meal and
i think through that you know it kind of
also plays into the role that you know
these banana trees they were fighting
against like marsha was talking about we
were fighting they were fighting against
these systems that were introduced not
necessarily against the banana trees but
the systems that kind of govern those
plantations especially as it relates to
um
you know those western monocultural
management management habits of the
thing right right
well all right when we come back i want
to
i want to actually hold you to the
braille here and get you to solve some
of these problems
and we're going to do that on star talk
when we return
we're back star talk our third and final
segment we're talking about
environmental science
and
indigenous peoples indigenous traditions
indigenous ways of interacting with
their environment and nature and
contrasting that with western ways
especially colonialistic western ways
which is a whole story unto itself and
we've got jessica hernandez
dr hernandez is one of the world's
experts on this subject and just
recently wrote a book called
fresh banana leaves and look i get the
title right here healing indigenous
landscapes through indigenous science
published earlier this year of course
i've got marcia belski uh welcome back
marcia because i know yes okay
so so jessica you we we've spent the
better part of a half hour describing
um you know evil european historical and
current ways and indigenous uh
challenges to that
how do we solve this problem
two i see two problems one of them is is
anyone ever gonna listen to indigenous
peoples who've been there way longer
than everybody else and a second
you can listen to them but how do we
know that's going to solve the larger
problem that we've created how do we
know that
i think we're seeing how
current international policy and also
national policy is trying to
understand that you know actually local
knowledge and listening to indigenous
peoples can help us mitigate climate
change we saw how this administration
recently passed a presidential
memorandum where president biden
actually says oh we should actually
incorporate local knowledge in
indigenous knowledge when it comes to
environmental regulations right but we
know that a memorandum is not actually
policy that states have to follow it's
just something that the president kind
of pledges to do
another thing that we're seeing is the
international panel on climate change
the ipcc recently submitted a report
where they're actually saying oh yeah
it's time for us to listen to indigenous
peoples as it relates to addressing
climate change impact so i think that
there is a lot of power
behind local knowledge especially local
indigenous knowledge to stored our
environments and i think that that all
relates to the land back movement and
for those who haven't heard of the land
back movement the land back movement is
kind of um a way that indigenous
communities are trying to get their land
back and not necessarily to own their
lands but because you know ownership is
a western construct but to steward and
caretake of their land especially the
indigenous communities who have
generations of history you know storing
those landscapes in that sense okay so
what's an example of something
indigenous wisdom can bring upon the
solutions that we're seeking
let me think of like for instance you
know we gave that example of my communi
myself with the community and how we
actually you know take care of our
forest i think another ways is even when
we look at indigenous communities and
how they're actually um
going against destructive energy
resources like recently we saw how in
ecuador the amazon race forest had over
5 300 barrels of oil spill even though
the indigenous communities of that
region were against that building of
those pipelines going through the amazon
rainforest right so
unfortunately and ironically has it
takes an environmental catastrophe or
environmental you know drastic event to
happen for people to be like oh actually
we should have listened to indigenous
communities from the start because you
know in that case they could have
prevented those
you know thousands of oil barrels
spilling in the amazon rainforest right
can i be a a colonist to capitalist just
for a brief second ready
five thousand barrels that's nothing you
got to see some of the other oils
that's a that's a light oil
exactly it sounds like
it feels like there's still a very
infantilizing approach to like native
communities where it's like very like
that's a good way to say it i agree 100
asking to help when we need it and like
you said mostly after the fact after a
catastrophe even laying blame
when it's like just to dodge blame for
like where the issues actually arise
from and then you see native people
working so hard
to preserve the land and to you know
just fight to be listened to and it
feels like
we could just
cut out so much of the bs by just
cutting out that first step of like
should we even listen to them will it
even work and it's like i think we've
seen pretty well what the issue is and
who knows what keeps the earth going
versus what kills it
i agree marcia completely but but
jessica isn't part of what you are
saying
to just leave stuff alone
so that's so
is that even policy to say leave it
alone that's just saying whatever you do
you're gonna kill it mess with it make
it worse so just leave it alone what i
was expecting was if you're gonna tell
me you've got some secret indigenous
wisdom that you'll say here do this
actively do something rather than not do
something the western colonists would
have done so is there something active
you can tell us to do
i think that um you know a lot of
indigenous knowledge is not necessarily
meant to be kept in secret right it's
sacred and i think that has to go back
with what marsha mentioned right how
sometimes when we have share indigenous
knowledge it has been co-opted and i
think an example that i can think of you
know she mentioned yoga
i can think of permaculture right
permaculture to get a certificate in
permaculture you have to pay hundreds of
dollars and permaculture is actually
stolen aborigine knowledge from the you
know indigenous peoples of australia
where a white cisgender man came and he
was like oh this is amazing let me
package it so that the western society
can consume it and we're going to call
that permaculture and for those who
don't look at the histories behind
certain disciplines or you know areas of
study you know they don't know that
that's actually
indigen you know co-opted indigenous
knowledge and i think that it's also
building better relationships where
we look at indigenous knowledge not to
be consumed but something like you were
mentioning neo that can be you know that
can help us mitigate climate change and
i think that unless we dismantle that
western way of thinking where everything
has to be sold where everything has to
be commodified you know indigenous
communities are going to be a little bit
receptive to sharing their indigenous
knowledge based on you know these past
cases so
as i understand it you have certain uh
shepherd
shepherding of forests given where you
your ancestry and something that's been
with earth ever since there's been earth
and forests are forest fires they've
been sort of picking up the pace lately
but nonetheless how did indigenous
peoples ever
deal with that because those can happen
very naturally with a dry season and a
lightning bolt
so one of the methods that you know it's
not that has been coined into a western
concept is known as prescribed burning
where you know it's kind of similar to
how we steward the timber in our zapotec
nation where we burn certain parts of
the tree in the forest so that prevents
you know it gets rid of that dry um you
know areas of the forest so that it
prevents future wildfires i know i gave
the example of milpas and milpas are
also
you know these holistic agricultural
systems that during the summer season
they actually burn themselves right it
doesn't necessarily require us to put it
on fire but those meal pass they're very
restorative in that sense that they burn
themselves and then that allows the
crops to regrow again and i think that
that's the same that the management
practices that we have embedded into our
forest is that prescribed burning to
prevent you know future wildfires in
that sense
okay so that's a that's a that's a
positive
outcome here i mean obviously the fires
are growing in frequency because of
other
more global climatic issues but
specifically if we think of fire as a
puzzle piece you have a puzzle piece
solution to a fire that has been shared
and has been implemented successfully
is that fair
yes and we're you know like you
mentioned it's starting to be picked up
so it's not necessarily like 100
implemented but it's getting there right
we're seeing that more in california in
washington we're seeing some areas that
you know the local firemen are actually
saying oh yeah we should actually learn
from the indigenous communities and do
these prescribed burnings to prevent
wildfires in the future and it's the
relationships like you said i feel like
it's hard because
we're still bridging that gap and it's
like why would
you know
in some ways even a local fire
department like you know even building
that relationship of like trusting the
indigenous people there and the
indigenous people trusting
you know the like western people there
enough to like
you know work as a team with all that
history there it feels like that's so
much of the solution here but
it's so complicated i've got another
question here so in this age of
jet transportation which has been with
us for about 60 years
no hardly anyone dies where they were
born
so this notion of
belonging to the land is that ship has
sailed
literally i guess but that uh
is that that's a that itself is a state
of mind
what what do you do about that going
forward into the era of
a cross-country intercontinental travel
yeah i think that often times it's a
matter of reclaiming our own histories
right because for instance in my
cybertech community our creation stories
tell us that when we you know pass on
our spirits enter the clouds right and
that's why um our you know nation is
considered the binisa people which means
the cloud people and as a result right
like our heaven if we were to look at it
from western religion in terms it's in
the clouds right and it's you know and
it shows uh the manifestation that we
we're still a part of nature because you
know what happens in the clouds we have
the water cycle right we get the water
the nourishes the plants the nourishes
the land and i think that you know
oftentimes we talk about how in ditch me
not being indigenous means holding on to
those relationships to that spirituality
even while you're displaced and you know
unfortunately for many people who have
been displaced like you're mentioning
because it you know you can travel or
you are forced to migrate you lose kind
of you fracture that identity but i
think it's important to reclaim our
histories especially when it relates to
the spirituality that still holds us
connected to those landscapes
so spirituality is not sort of a
fundamental part of modern science so
how do you bridge that gap
i think it takes us to relearn and
unlearn the ways that we have been
taught science especially when it comes
to you know being objective because when
we look at the foundations of many signs
and for instance you know some somebody
who's studying the concept of energy we
know that the concept of energy was
actually created during the british
industrial revolution right so there was
a lot of western religion yeah embedded
in that concept of energy but when we
practice energy from the environmental
physics lens we tell ourselves oh yeah
it's not social political it doesn't
have any ties to our society it's an
abstract concept that cannot be seen or
perceived but in reality when we look at
the history of that concept is very
embedded in that religion in that you
know british industrial industrial
revolution believes but somehow there's
a disconnection between the history and
how we're told to practice that today so
how would how should someone practice it
today
someone gets a degree in physics what
would you want how would you want to see
that
you want them to read up on indigenous
ways just so that where they can or
should fold it in it's available to them
because right now of course we're not
even exposed
even if there were something yeah and i
think that um you know i currently work
with a lot of physics teachers
especially teachers who teach in the
secondary educational system because you
know physics is a secondary educational
topic that's taught everywhere and i
think that one of the ways that we can
do that is even by integrating equity
right when we look at you know teachers
serving black and brown students a lot
of you know the energy
impacts that it has in societies is
actually impacting the students
community so it's not just looking at
the indigenous ways of knowing which i
think it's a great step to do but also
looking at the societal implications
that the concept of energy has through
place-based education right like someone
who grew up in south central los angeles
there are so many examples that i can
think of how energy actually created
more environmental pollution and how
that's related to the high asthma rates
that you know we suffer as children
living in south central los angeles
so that's energy produced by fossil
fuels but you can make energy other ways
that wouldn't
pose that risk
so
that that's a factor as well
um and and
you know marcia when i kept hearing this
thing about a puzzle and whether it's
holistic i was just wondering if in a
stand-up routine is an isolated joke a
puzzle piece but you only give a really
good performance if it all fits together
and makes one big puzzle at the end you
get a bigger applause if it's holistic
yeah i feel like because yeah think
about if somebody had like a five minute
set on late night and they had one good
joke but the rest of it bombed like
unless it was like i don't think you
there could be any joke good enough
where you wouldn't be like
that guy was terrible
like
because unless he's like a one-liner but
then you'd be like how come only one of
them's good why is he on my tv
you know
all the pieces gotta fit together for it
to make sense i feel like that makes
sense too with like getting people in
physics classrooms just to have
different
perspectives because different
perspectives lead to less blind spots so
it's like i feel like you get more
indigenous people and more spirituality
just to have a seat at the table
so jessica maybe that's
more of what we need just a seat at the
table here
just so that the the view can be aired
in front of those who never even knew
the view existed
yeah and sometimes you know even our
elders tell us that sometimes we have to
build our own tables and leave those
tables because oftentimes when we get a
seat at the table we're seen but not
hurt and i think that you know it kind
of depends on who is inviting us at the
table and whether they're actually
willing to hear us as well and listen to
what we have to offer well okay so we
gotta
land this plane and
that means we're running out of time
sorry
sorry to use a technological reference
here but uh we'll land this plane so
jessica it seems to me there many more
books you can write or that can be
written if not by you by others with a
slightly different expertise that have
these same tap roots
that can just wake up the world to how
to think about earth differently so have
you given up hope as so many others have
or do you still think we can save the
world that's a loaded question
yeah you're gonna you're i feel like i'm
in my therapy session yeah
but i think where are you on the
extinction issue of human species yes
haven't given up hope and i think that
you know even being able to say that i
wrote a book especially a book that
uplift of lists also my community's
voices and knowing that i have that
privilege right that comes with having a
phd we're having that educational system
in the western terminology right where i
can talk to scientists in the united
nations and they actually listen to me
because you know i'm not just using you
know laypersons terminology which is
unfortunate right because we're still
operating in western science where we
need that terminology i think that you
know that gives me hope especially
seeing how my father was able to survive
with genocide that you know even though
even though it was coined as a war the
united nations has identified that as a
genocide because it it actually targeted
indigenous mayan people in central
america i think that that gives me hope
and also seeing how there's you know
other people in our generation trying to
move the needle especially when it comes
to including voices of communities of
color in that sense well so now you get
me sad that i didn't have you on years
ago
if this put you a seat at the star talk
table and it's like the year 2022 and i
hope that's not too late uh so so
jessica thank you for that that
marvelous closing statement i guess it
sounded like uh and uh maybe we can do
this again when there's more
developments because we always like
tracking stories that
that we're introduced to here on star
talk but we want to see where they go uh
in the years to come
so thank you for being on star talk and
and and marcia where do we find you on
social media yeah find me on social
media it's at marsha belsky on twitter
and tick tock and then my instagram is
at marsha sky cool cool and uh jessica
are there are there websites or
organizations we should know about that
you support or that you can uh resonate
with other people can sort of share
resident energy and possibly money
to the causes resonant money is the best
kind so where do you want to send people
yeah so i usually leave mutual aids and
mutual aids you know they support the
communities especially projects and i
usually um share them in my twitter
which is at doctor and underscore nature
and i think that that's where people can
find dr nature
nature yes
you you have doc doctor nature
oh my gosh
okay that's gangster right there that's
forget my name i i am nature
doctor is it an underscore it goes
straight in
underscore nature yes so doctor
underscore nature okay well that's going
to be easy to find all right guys great
to have you and this has been star talk
the indigenous people's edition
neil degrasse tyson here you're a
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
[Music]
you